being strong and being explosive are not
the same thing
a strong individual is someone who can
move something extremely heavy from
point a to point b
an explosive individual is somebody
capable of running fast
changing direction quickly and jumping
high into the air they can also deliver
snappy punches and throw things long
distances
they exert strength but they do so very
quickly
how do you become more explosive then
the first place many people will turn to
is plyometric training however there's a
lot of confusion surrounding what
plyometric training actually is and what
it isn't
there's even more confusion surrounding
how to use it effectively and when to
turn to other similar tools
so let's jump in jump
like in plyometric box jumps plyometric
exercises
utilize rapid bursts of power with a
minimal ground contact time
in order to utilize the stretch
shortening cycle
an example is a counter movement jump
here the athlete lowers themselves
rapidly eccentric phase
pauses extremely briefly amortization
phase
then springs up into the air to land on
a box or other raised platform
concentric phase the term plyometric is
a little nebulous and open to
interpretation however
the stretch shortening cycle means that
you're lengthening and then contracting
the working muscles in a very short time
frame
this is something we do intuitively all
the time such as when you wind up a
punch
this is often described as being a way
to tap into the stored energy that comes
from stretching the muscle
like an elastic band this is incorrect
however
in fact the power of the stretch
shortening cycle appears to come from
the time the muscle spends
in the active state this allows for more
cross bridges to form inside the muscles
thereby giving the more traction as it
were to then exert
force the lengthening phase therefore
acts more like a run-up
but spend too long in the stretch
position and you'll lose some of that
potential because you're
no longer active that's why it's harder
and not easier to jump out of a squat
unless you just dropped into it very
briefly the former is an isometric
concentric movement
the latter is a plyometric concentric
movement this also means that the ground
contact time is actually not as
important as the time the muscles spend
in the active state thus a counter
movement jump from the ground is still
plyometric
that said there is also benefits to
minimizing ground contact time in other
scenarios if you want to become
truly explosive enter the verkoshansky
depth jump and shock training the best
example is the verkoshansky depth jump
this involves jumping off a raised
platform around 42 inches for maximum
benefit
and then launching back off the ground
after less than 0.2 seconds
this collision engages the myotatic
stretch response
the sudden lengthening of the muscles
causes them to then rapidly contract in
response
and this in turn allows the athlete to
draw upon huge reserves of explosive
strength
this same collision is also seen in
sprinting
over time practicing this will increase
the athlete's eccentric strength
as well as training the central nervous
system to anticipate the myotactic
reflex
and thus increase firing rate in short
athletes get a lot more explosive
and in one study volleyball players were
shown to gain a 14
increase in jump height using a depth
jump program
by the way if you want to see all the
studies that support all this
then head over to the link in the
description down below and read the
written version of this post
to turn the explosive push up into an
example of shock training we would need
to jump on each repetition
while keeping the time on the ground to
0.2 seconds or below
all while properly absorbing the impact
to avoid injury
this could translate to even more
explosive punching and throwing
and have useful benefit for max bench
press
that said there are also some rebound
elements involved in most explosive
movements
this is where athletic properties such
as ankle stiffness become important
tendon hysteresis describes how pliable
a tendon is
where lower hysteresis equals less
pliability when running an athlete's
calf actually plays a somewhat minimal
role during plantar flexion
as a lot of energy is returned by the
stiffness of the tendon
thus it can make more sense to think of
the muscles in terms of muscle tendon
units
fascia the thin film wrap that covers
the muscles organs and more
which i mentioned in almost every single
video also has elastic properties and is
able to return energy to the ground
think of it like being coated in a thin
layer of flubber
one of the most crucial things to
understand when utilizing plyometrics
is inter-serial rest periods rest times
between sets
if you are programming plyometrics or
shock training then you should also
include sufficient rest time
this is not quite as straightforward as
some vocal individuals on the web would
have you believe however
the argument goes that in order to
trigger useful adaptations with
plyometrics
you need a long recovery period this
then allows the individual to exert 100
of their max effort during each rep when
performing plyometrics
it has been suggested that this should
be in the region of two to five minutes
of intercept rest however other studies
call into question just how strictly
we should adhere to this one study for
example found meaningful improvements in
athletes using 30
60 and 120 second rest periods there was
no significant difference between those
groups
that said going longer during
inter-serial rest periods
still makes a lot of sense and is
generally standard practice the argument
for longer rest periods is that if you
don't rest sufficiently
then you won't be able to call upon your
max effort when you perform subsequent
reps of jumps
that's the key here max effort jumping
as high as possible
is akin to performing your one rep max
you're giving a hundred percent
and this is what you need to do if you
want to increase jump height and rapid
force production
to jump higher you need to create the
demand for jumping higher
by regularly trying to jump as high as
possible thus we should also use a
similar approach to rest times
and number of repetitions as though we
were training with max weights
number of repetitions should be
somewhere in the region of four to five
maximum
if the aim is to increase jump height
for example and rest time should be long
enough
to ensure max effort the next go round
the number of repetitions is also
limited by the amount of time we can
spend performing a set of plyometrics
after all this is a form of train that
uses the phosphogen lactic acid or
atp creatine system for rapid energy
release
that means we can't maintain good effort
for much longer than 10 seconds
how many reps can you cram into that
time to answer that we must also
consider the intra serial rest time
in other words how long should you pause
between each repetition
we already know the answer if we're
talking about depth jumps and shock
training
0.2 seconds otherwise the intra-serial
rest will be determined by the nature of
the exercise itself
there is an unavoidable rest period in
counter-movement jumps for example
of course fatigue also increases the
likelihood of injury
this is particularly important in any
exercise that involves leaping off of
heights
and absorbing large amounts of shock
should the athletes slip or allow their
knee to collapse inwards it's game over
this is true in general when using
plyometrics and especially things like
box jumps
make sure that there are no valgus knees
and that you are properly absorbing the
shock as you land
but it's also important to realize that
training plyometrics at higher rep
ranges and with less recovery
is not pointless as some would have you
believe for one this trains the ability
to call upon explosive force
even in a fatigued state this of course
is how we are often required to be
explosive in sports and in life
we can also combine plyometrics with
strength training the problem with
strength training for increasing running
speed
is that the ground contact time for a
sprinter is around 90 milliseconds
this is not enough time to tap into max
strength and so the rate of force
development is more important
the rate at which the sprinter can
generate power the rate at which they
can recruit the necessary motor units
it's combining plyometrics with strength
training that could result in the
greatest rapid recruitment
of type 2x muscle fibers complex
training therefore does exactly that it
combines strength training
with a matched plyometric movement for
example you might perform bench press
followed by explosive push-ups or squats
followed by counter movement jumps
complex training appears to work via
post-activation potentiation
this means that the muscle fibers and
nerves are primed for action
this is the same reason you feel super
light jumping after you've been
squatting with a weighted vest
neurons and spinal nerves that
coordinate the movement don't return to
their previous resting potential
meaning a weaker signal is required to
reactivate them it's also postulated
that the actin and myosin within the
muscles
become more sensitive to calcium from
the sarcoplasmic reticulum
generally it is performed with reps
using roughly 85 percent of the one rep
maximum
followed by lighter plyometrics this is
an advanced
technique though and not necessary for
most people
plyometric training is not the only way
to increase explosiveness
take the kettlebell swing for example
swinging kettlebell is an example of
ballistic training
this is about acceleration and power but
without necessarily including the
stretch shortening component
does this still build explosiveness in a
word yes
any time you're required to generate
force against resistance
and the aim is velocity you are
developing power and explosiveness
more specifically you're working on rate
of force development
this means you're training yourself to
recruit muscle fibers quickly
which is what you need when operating in
nearly any athletic environment
even among power lifters aiming to move
the bar quickly during strength training
will recruit more type 2x muscle fibers
which will result in faster strength
gains in short it's as though you are
adding just a little bit extra weight
onto the bar this is also why we see
strength athletes
using compensatory acceleration here
they practice using lighter weights on
some days
but combine that with greater
acceleration to compensate
the west side barbell system refers to
this as the dynamic
effort method ideally you should train
using fifty to seventy percent
of your one rep maximum to increase
neural drive
giving you greater control over your
strength and allowing you to explode out
the bottom of a given movement
and that is why bar speed is such a
useful measure too coaches look at how
quickly an athlete is moving the weight
and adjust accordingly the problem is
that when the weight gets too heavy
we're not able to move with enough speed
the intent changes
we're now grinding through the movement
if your squat max is going up
but your vertical is staying the same
try the dynamic effort method
this is also why sprinters training with
the sled pull saw improvements in their
running speed until they upped the
weight
to beyond 75 of their body weight and
this is another very important point to
consider
relative strength the lighter you are
the lesser max strength you need in
order to move
explosively it doesn't matter how much
you lift it matters
how quickly you can lift your own body
weight what should be standing out to
you here
is that this is very much a mental game
it's about the intent with which you
perform the movement
if you aim to get through a set of
push-ups the result will be very
different than if you aim to perform
them as quickly and powerfully as
possible
it doesn't even matter if you move you
can increase rate of force development
using ballistic isometrics too
these involve pushing or pulling
explosively against an immovable object
as quickly as you can
so you might push against the wall and
suddenly give a burst of effort
this could be another effective tool for
contrast training too that would
minimize fatigue
if used correctly this is also why it
can be useful to train using some kind
of external cue
if you want to develop a true
explosiveness strength is useless in a
vacuum
so why not aim to jump on command get a
spotter to blow a whistle at random
intervals
you could even use two different tones
but only jump when you hear one of them
in order to learn both reaction and
action suppression
this is once again where training goes
from theoretical and detached
to genuinely useful and applicable
so that's a pretty comprehensive primer
on training for explosiveness
i hope you guys found this one useful
and interesting if you did please leave
a like and share around
that would help me out immensely
subscribe and hit the notification
button if you want to see more like this
if you want to learn more about
functional training that can have real
world benefits for athletes and everyone
else
then check out my newly published book
functional training and beyond
and thank you so much to all of you for
your amazing support since the launch of
the book
it's been doing great if you read it and
enjoyed it please consider leaving a
review on amazon
as that can really help me to get that
early momentum going and if you're
looking for a training program that can
improve speed strength mobility
brain function and more check out my
ebook and training program
super functional training that's
available in the link down below and
there's a discount on right now
while so many of us are still in
lockdown either way thank you so much
again for watching this one guys
and bye for now
[Music]
you